وصل سته مسؤولين صينيين تايوان في زياره
هي الاولى منذ ثلاث سنوات بدعوه من
السلطات في العاصمه
لحضور تظاهرات ثقافيه زياره تتزامن واخرى
يؤديها مسؤول سياسه الصينيه فينتاجون الى
الجزيره التي تمثل احد محاور توتر متصاعدا
بين وعشره وبيجين التي دعا الامين العام
لحلف الناتو لعدم تكرار ما وصفه بخطا
روسيا في التعامل معها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما الذي ال اليه
التوتر بين الصين والولايات المتحده على
وقع زياره مسؤولين من كليهما الى تايوان
وجديد تصريحات قاده البلدين بشان الملفات
الخلافيه بينهما كيف تبدو خيارات البلدين
في اداره حاله التوتر بينهما سواء تعلق
الامر بارتدادات قضيه المنطاد او ما استجد
من تصريحات وتحركات فيما يتعلق بالخلاف
حول تايوان وغيرهما من القضايا ما الفرص
الممكنه لتلاف انزلاق الازمه الراهنه بين
واشنطن نحو مراحل اخرى من التصعيد تنذر
بحسب تحذيرات لمواجهه بينهما وهل هناك
امكانيه للانصات للاصوات الداعيه للتهدئه
بين البلدين
[موسيقى]
الى كل من ميونخ تطلعت انظار المتابعين
لاخر تطورات التوتر المتصاعدي بين
الولايات المتحده والصين فالى الاولى
تقاطر مسؤولون صينيون وامريكيون في زيارات
لا تخلو من دلالات رمزيه وعمليه ذات بال
ومن الثانيه صدرت خلال مؤتمرها الدوري
للامن تصريحات سلطه الضوء ولو بمقدار على
ما يفكر فيه قاده البلدين في المرحله التي
بلغتها الخلافات بينهما وزير الخارجيه
الصيني شدد من المانيا على ان تايوان لم
تكن يوما ولن تكون في المستقبل بلدا مشيرا
الى ان ما وصفها بالقوات الانفصاليه
التايوانيه تهدد وحده الصين اضاف المسؤول
الصيني ان واشنطن لم تنصت لدعوات بيجين
للتعامل مع ازمه المنطاد بهدوء ومهنيه
وفضلت ان تنتهيج سياسه وصفها بالهستيريه
قائلا اسقاط المنطاد الصيني لم يظهر قوه
الولايات المتحده بل العكس الولايات
المتحده التي قالت ان انهت انها انهت
عمليه انتشار بقايا المنطاد الصيني قال
رئيسها
لا تريد حربا بارده اخرى مؤكدا انه يعتزم
لقاء نظيره الصيني لحديثا في العمق بشان
ملابسات قضيه المنطاد الصيني وفيما تطلعت
الانظار الى لقاء محتمل بين وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي
ونظيره الصيني قال المبعوث الامريكي الخاص
لشؤون المناخ جون كيري انه على الصين
والولايات المتحده تجاوز قضيه المنطاد
لمناقشه قضايا اخرى اهم بكثير
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من واشنطن
الدكتور ديفيد سيدني نائب مساعد وزير
الدفاع الامريكي السابق لشؤون الامن
القومي في اسيا ومن بيجين معنا رونغه
الاعلامي والباحث في الشؤون الاسيويه
مرحبا بكما سنبدا معك
التوتر يتصاعد بين الولايات المتحده
والصين في قضيه المنطاد قبلها وخلالها
قضيه تايوان
والان الازمه او العلاقه بين الصين وروسيا
ورغم كل ذلك نجد الرئيس الامريكي يتحدث عن
انه يعتزم الحديث الى نظيره الصيني لانه
لا يريد حربا بارده او مواجهه كيف نفهم ما
يحصل
اعتقدوا ان هناك مصلحه حقيقيه لدى
الولايات المتحده والصين بان يكون لديهما
علاقه تسمح بالتناقش بمباعث القلق والامور
والاهتمامات المشتركه من مثل اجتياح
اوكرانيا والتغير المناخي ان حادثه
المنطاد تشتت الانتباه عن المسائل
الاساسيه التهديد الامني الاول في العالم
اليوم هو اجتياح روسيا الوحشي غير
القانوني لاوكرانيا وهنا يتعين على الصين
ان تؤدي دورا لكي تنسحب روسيا من اوكرانيا
ثانيا كوريا الشماليه وهي جاره الصين
اطلقت صاروخا بالستيان اخر وان كوريا
الشماليه هي تهديد لمنطقه الشرق اسيا
ولولايات المتحده الامريكيه والصين يمكنها
ان تساعد في هذا المجال كذلك لذلك امل ان
الولايات المتحده والصين سوف تتباحثان
بالنسبه الى هذه المواضيع وتبتعدان عن
استخدام مصطلحات تصعيديه من مثل هيستيريه
وهذا يسهل عمليه الحوار رون روان ماذا عن
سهم الصين للتصرف الامريكي مع العلم ان
الصين تلقي باللائمه على الولايات المتحده
بانها تستفز تقوم باستفزاز الصين
اهلا ومرحبا بكم
ترى الصين ان الولايات المتحده لا يمكن ان
تتحدث مع سن الحوار والتفاوض وانت تعاون
وفي نفس الوقت
اقوم
بالتحركات
لاحتواء الصين
يجب على البلدين البدل الجهوري مشتركه
لتوسيع نقاط التعاون وكذلك على اساس
المساواه واحترام المتبادل ولتحقيق
التعايش السلمي
وكذلك تحقيق الفوز المشتركه من خلال
التعارف يعني سيد رونج سترفض الصين الحديث
الى الرئيس بايدن وهو يعتزم ان كما قال في
تصريحات له ان يتحدث الى نظيره الصيني
سترفض هذه المبادره من الصين باعتقادك
ترحب باي
الاتصال المباشر بين
البلدين على مختلف المستويات ولكن ترى سن
ان هذا هذه
الحوارات او اتصالات يجب ان تكون على اساس
الاحترام المتبادل والمساوات
ولذلك كما قلت قبل قليل الصين لا تريد ان
تتحدث الولايات المتحده مع الصناعه وفي
نفس الوقت تقوم بريحه طيب اين
الصين ان الولايات المتحده
تتحرك لاحتوائها كما قلت اين ترى ان هناك
عدم احترام وعدم
مساواه في التعامل في اي ملفات تحديدا
مثلا في
فقط ممكنه ان نرى قبيل
الخطه زياره وزير الخارجيه الامريكي الصين
وفي نفس الوقت
الولايات المتحده فقط حدا شهر
زياده التواجد العسكريه
في
منطقه
المشاوره للصين وكذلك
تشكيل التحالفات مع الدول الدوار وكذلك
ارسال
الوفود الرسميه الى زياره التايبان وهذه
القضيه الحساسه مع الصين وكذلك
تقوم بفرض عقوبات على الشركات الصينيه وكل
هذه قبل الزياره
وهذا يعني غير منطقي يعني اذا كان الدوله
ستكون بزياره رسميه واوديه لدوله اخرى لا
يجب ان تقوم بهذه التحركات دكتور
زياده التواجد العسكري في المناطق المحيطه
بالصين زياده التحركات الامريكيه الرسميه
باتجاه التايوان وعقوبات على شركات
الصينيه هذا ما تقوم به الولايات المتحده
تجاه الصين ثم تقول انها لا تريد مواجهه
كيف ترد على هذا الامر
متاكد من انكم تعرفون ان الصين فرضت
عقوباتنا على الشركات الامريكيه والصين
توسع التواجد العسكري من خلال بناء قواعد
جديده في افريقيا وفي اماكن اخرى وبالتالي
الصين توسع تواجدها العسكري لذلك يتعين
على كلا الطرفين وهما من بين القوى العظمى
في العالم ان يتخاطب مع بعضهما البعض
بالنسبه الى المسائل التي فيها احتمال
نزاع ولكن ايضا فيها احتمال تعاون يجب على
البلدين ان يتفادي الكلمات من نوع هستيريا
الى اخره وفي كلا البلدين هناك
احزاب متعدده وافكار متعدده في الولايات
المتحده هناك بعض من يدعو الى التشدد ضد
الصين وفي الصين الامر سيئا لذلك يتعين
على القياده شيجنتن في الصين ورئيس بايدن
في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اذا على
الزعيمين ان يتخطيا هذه المساله لكي نصل
الى السلام عوضا عن تجديد النزاع لكن يقول
السيد
ان هناك هذا الشعور لدى الصين بانه يجري
التعامل معها على طريقه احتوائها على
طريقه تقويدها على طريقه انها غير مساويه
عدم عدم مساواه وعدم احترام لدورها ماذا
بيد الولايات المتحده ان تفعل من اجل
طمانه الصين بالحد الادنى والشروع في هذا
الحوار حتى تضع حد للتوتر المتصاعد
المساله الحقيقيه ليست ما تقوم به
الولايات المتحده في الحقيقه المساله
ترتبط بالصين الصين توسع تواجد العسكري في
العالم وتتخذ خطوات ضد الشركات الامريكيه
وشركات اخرى وهي تمنع التدفق الحر
للمعلومات بالنسبه الى الشعب الصيني هناك
قيود فرضتها الصين والتوسع تقوم به الصين
وهذا ما يجب التطرق اليه لا نتحدث هنا عن
دور الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لطمنت
الصين بل يتعين على كلا الطرفين ان يطمئن
الواحد الاخر هناك بوعد قلق في البلدين لا
يمكننا ان نلقي اللوم على واحد دون الاخر
يجب ان نمضي قدما بطريقه تؤمن التعاون وكي
لا يصبح وتصبح هذه المواضيع مصدرا للنزاع
استمعت لكل هذه الامور كيف ترد ماذا عن
الصين في هذا الاطار
طبعا الصين مبدا الصين تجاه العلاقات
الصينيه الامريكيه والاحترام المتبادل
والتعايش السلمي
والتعاون وفوز المشتركه فالصين يعني ظلت
تدعم مع علاقاتها مع الولايات المتحده على
اساس هذه المبادئ ويمكن ان نرى هناك دائما
التحركات الامريكيه لاحتوائسين في يعني في
البدايه وثم
يقول ان الصين هي التي تقوم بالتوسع
عسكريا
حدد لك افريقيا مثالا على ذلك
يعني كل ما تفعله لزياده قدراته الدفاعيه
هو من اجل الدفاع عن نفسها
يعني تتماسك بسياسه الدفاع ذاتي طبيعه
الدفاعيه وسينه
يعني تتحقق
وايضا دوله الوحيده في العالم بين دول
التي تملك الاسلحه النوويه بانه
لن تستخدموا لنده تبادر في استخدام
الاسلحه النوويه والناس
السن هي الدوله الوحيده كذلك يعني تدعوا
التنميه السلميه في دستورها وهي تتماسك
بطريقه التنميه سلميه وكذلك ليس لديها اي
تاريخ لعضو للقيام باحتلال شبر من اعراض
الدول الاخرى
ابدا في شؤون داخليه لدول اخرى فلذلك
يعني صعود الصيني هو الصعود السلمي
وهي النمو القوه الصينيه يعني النمو
الزياده تكون السلام في العالم فلذلك لا
توجد هذه
المخاوف
يعني لذلك فقط الولايات المتحده في يعني
في اعتقاد سنترى
تخاف يعني تقلق من فقدانها لحيمنتها على
العالم
ما يمكن وصفها بحرب التصريحات بين الصين
والولايات المتحده قال المتحدث باسم
البنتاجون العقيد مايكل ان الدعم الامريكي
والعلاقه الدفاعيه مع تايوان لا يزالان
قويين ضدما وصفه بالتهديد الحالي الذي
تشكله الصين في هذه الاثناء ذكرت صحيفه ان
البيت الابيض سيعقد اجتماعا مع مسؤولين
تايوانيين كبار الاسبوع المقبل في واشنطن
لاجراء محادثات تقرر ان تكون خاصه لتجنب
رد فعل غاضبا من الصين
اعود اليك تحديدا في موضوع تايوان لماذا
في هذه
الان يعني في خضم هذا التوتر القائم مع
الصين بسبب ازمه المنطاد يتم من جديد
ارسال
مسؤول تايوان في البنتاجون الى الجزيره
والتحضير لعقد هذه الاجتماعات مع مسؤولينا
تايوانيين في واشنطن
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لديها علاقه
واسعه نطاق مع تايوان وهي بالنسبه الى
التزام ومرتبطه بالتزام المتحده الامريكيه
تجاهها الصين ان الهدف في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وحل السلمي لمساله
تايوان والولايات المتحده والصين اتفقتا
في مرحله ما ولكن لسوء الحظ في السنوات
الاخيره الصين اتخذت موقفا عسكريا من خلال
ارسال السفن الحربيه والطائرات الحربيه في
الاجواء التايوانيه من اجل محاصره تايوان
وبالتالي اصبحت الصين اكثر عدوانيه تجاه
تايوان وهذا ما ادى الى رد فعل من جانب
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اذا ما توقفت
الصين عن تهديداتها تجاه تايوان سوف تكون
المنطقه اكثر امنا والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لا يتعين عليها بالتالي ان ترد
على الاعتداء العسكري الصيني الم
تقم اجتياز الحدود الجويه
لتايوان
وارسال رسائل عسكريه سواء لتايوان او
للولايات المتحده
استدعت هذا التقارب الامريكي التايواني
طبعا
التايوان هي جزء لا يتجزا من الاراضي
الصينيه يعني
[موسيقى]
سياده الصين على حيوانها فهذا امر
يعني تم اعتراف بها الدوليه وكذلك
الولايات المتحده
فلذلك
هناك تعهدات
حتى الان
هي كان
تقبلها من قبل الحزبكم من دعم يعني ولكن
بعد اصول حزب التقدم الديمقراطي في
الاعمال 2016 رفض مبدا سنه واحد وكان قبل
ذلك تلتزم بمبدا الواحد
هي ترفض يعني تايوان رسميا ترفض هذا
المبدا
طبعا لانه حاليا هو
الانفصاليون في سلطه حاليا
يعني بتعرفوا دول المبدا الصيني الواحد
ولذلك
الولايات المتحده ايضا على حتى
هناك التعاقدات
رئيس بايدن بانه الولايات المتحده على
استقلال تمام
واحد ولكن في الواقع هناك تناقضات بين
اقوالها والافعالها وكذلك يعني تقوم بدعم
تايلان في
الاستمرار في زيارات رسميه لها فهذا ايضا
تخالف والتعهدات امام امام الصين وكذلك
التعاقدات
يقول لك سيد رونج ان
التهديد الصيني لتايوان هو الذي دفع
الولايات المتحده الى الخروج عن هذه
السياسه التي كانت متابعه سابقا التهديد
الصيني لسياده او
لوضع تايوان الخاص هو الذي دفع بالولايات
المتحده الى تاكيد التزامها بيئه من هذه
الجزيره
اريد رد منك على هذه النقطه نعم دعني
اشرح هذه الفلسفه نفسها فيها الفلسفه
خاطئه ليس يعني الشروط هو ليس التحديدات
الصينيه فالصين لم تحدد لان يجوز لا
يتجاذب من الاراضي الصينيه
وهناك
الاستفزازات في البدايه من قبل
الانكساريين في تايلاند اعتمادا على
الولايات المتحده والدعم الولايات المتحده
وهذا ما جعل الغضب
البروسيني الرئيسيه
[موسيقى]
لجعل
الجيش الحرير الشعبي الصيني للدفاع عن
سياده الدوله واذا كان يمكن ان نرى كذلك
اذا كان هناك اي تواتر واذا كان الولايات
المتحده تريد فرد
فدائما تستخدم تايوان
ورقه الضغط
الضغوط على يمكن ان نرى الطواقي يعني
مواعيد والتوقيت
الارسال الولايات المتحده
رسميه وبيع الاسلحه لها فكلها من ذلك من
اجل
يعني فرض المزيد من الضغوط على الصين وهذا
ايضا يدل على ان هي فقط ورقه الضغط من قبل
الى ولايه المتحده للصين
في خضام كل هذا التوتر بين
القوتين الكبريين في العالم ما السبيل
لتخفيض نسبه هذا هذا التوتر الحاصل حاليا
كما سبق وقلت هناك مشكله متعدده يواجهها
العالم في الجانب الامني بعد الاجتياح غير
القانوني الروسيه لاوكرانيا وهو التهديد
الامنيه الاكبر في عالمنا اليوم وصولا الى
التغير المناخي والتهديد
فيانغ
للامن الاقليمي هذه المجالات التي يتعين
على الولايات المتحده والصين ان تعمل مع
بعضهما البعض لوقف الاعتداء الروسي
وللتعامل مع تغير المناخ وايضا لوقف كوريا
الشماليه من تهديد الجيران شكرا لك سنكتفي
بهذا القدر هذا كل ما يسمح به لنا وقتنا
شكرا لك
نائب مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكيه السابق
لشؤون الامن القومي في اسيا وشكرا لرونغو
وان الاعلامي والبحث في الشؤون الاسيويه
ضيفنا من بيجي
الى هنا مشاهدينا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر شكرا لمتابعتكم والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]